OK, so let's get into now an interview that
is like nothing I have ever seen in the United
States.
This is an interview in which Donald Trump
finally out of his bunker of media isolation
after losing to Joe Biden, has started doing
media again on Thanksgiving.
He took some questions from reporters, which
we will get to.
But I'm starting here with his interview yesterday
morning on Fox News with Maria Bartiromo.
This interview is indistinguishable from a
North Korean state media reporter.
Maria Bartiromo went along with Donald Trump's
obvious lies with the same credulity as those
North Korean state media anchors when they
used to report on Kim Jong Il, got a hole
in one on all 18 holes.
Kim Jong un doesn't defecate, right?
I mean, it's like that what Maria Bartiromo
does here, Trump told endless lie after lie,
many of them completely corrosive to our democracy.
And she went along with every single one.
And then just to add insult to injury, or
maybe better said, to add a cartoonish element
to this, Donald Trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him to
lose the election, which is just like on another
level altogether from from the standpoint
of comedy.
So let's get right into it, because we do
have so much to get to check this out, combining
here the search routine with this new massive
dump's meme and what happened to be watched
the election.
I was called by the biggest people saying
congratulations, political people.
Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
It was 10:00 o'clock and you looked at the
numbers and I'm sure you felt that way.
This election was over.
And then they did dump's they call them dump's
big massive dumps in Michigan and Pennsylvania.
It's it's just beyond parody.
A massive dump's cost them the election.
Huge dumps were happening all over the country
as the results were coming in.
What is going on here?
We are a laughing stock.
And in this in this next clip, Donald Trump
pushes completely baseless voter fraud conspiracies.
And if you're watching, pay special attention
to the looks on Maria Bartiromo Face.
She's acting like when Trump says maybe the
FBI was involved, she reacts as if, wow, the
FBI is really involved in this.
This is total fraud and how the FBI and Department
of Justice, I don't know, maybe they're involved,
but how people are allowed to get away from
this stuff with this stuff is unbelievable.
This election was rigged.
This election was a total fraud and it continues
to be as they hide.
And the problem we have, we go to judges and
people don't want to get involved.
What Trump means there by we go to judges
and they don't want to get involved.
What he means is judges look at our so-called
evidence and find it completely lacking in
merit.
That's actually what's going on here.
Is Trump just straight up saying the popular
vote numbers are wrong, ballot boxes and they
use covid as a means to stuff the ballot boxes.
Joe Biden did not get sixteen million more
votes than Barack Hussein Obama.
He didn't get it.
Joe Biden did not get fourteen million more
votes than Hillary Clinton.
And by the way, he didn't beat Obama in the
black communities.
You go to some of these communities where
Obama is very, very popular and he beats them
in some of these communities, but all throughout
the rest of the United States, in a black
community, he does he does actually poorly.
He doesn't do very well.
This one should not surprise any of us.
Remember that Donald Trump still hasn't accepted
the results of the popular vote from twenty
sixteen.
That was an election that made Trump president.
And so, as we've been saying for months, obviously,
Trump was never going to accept the 2020 popular
vote results and he's not.
And then Maria Bartiromo goes full propaganda
actor.
She says, listen, if you don't consider the
electoral votes of the contested swing states,
you win.
Mr. President, a critical part of this story,
Mr. President, but if you take out the contested
swing states electoral votes, you're back
down to President Trump having two hundred
and thirty two electoral votes and Joe Biden
having two hundred and twenty seven.
That is if you strip out the six states with
the legal challenges.
So that is the thinking here, that because
of the various ballot issues that the Supreme
Court will roll, that the vote is tainted
and that will mean that they have to take
votes away from Biden and not certify.
Is that the thinking?
And secondly, what's your timing on this,
Mr. President?
Because.
We've got some notable election dates here
that I want to ask you, this reminds me of
the old Internet viral phrase If my grandmother
had wheels instead of legs, she would be a
bicycle.
The point is, that's not the situation.
Swing states are part of the country.
Swing states have not been shown to have had
fraudulent results.
The swing states merely count like any others.
You don't get to not count them because the
results are inconvenient.
And Maria Bartiromo really outdoing herself
here.
And Trump then goes on completely delusional
to talk about assertions of hundreds of thousands
of votes that are just fraud and anything
to not admit.
He simply lost the election and quite decisively.
But we actually have thousands of votes, in
some cases hundreds of thousands of votes,
more than we need in every swing state that
we're talking about.
So then here comes in Maria Bartiromo on a
bizarre rant and she says, This is all disgusting,
Mr. President.
This is disgusting.
And we cannot allow America's election to
be corrupted.
We cannot.
So you believe you can prove that the computers
can circumvent any controls that are in place?
And before we leave the subject of Durham,
not only is Maria making no sense, why is
she screaming the entire interview?
It's really bizarre.
And this finally starts to wind down.
And Maria Bartiromo interview ends with Trump
saying it's statistically impossible what
happened.
And Maria Bartiromo responds by saying, It's
all quite extraordinary, Mr. President.
They say it's statistically impossible.
I led the charge.
We won state houses, we won Congress, we won
the Senate and I lost.
They say it's statistically impossible for
that to happen.
It's all quite extraordinary, Mr. President,
we want to thank you so much for joining me
today and thank you for your work.
Yes, all quite extraordinary telling obvious
lies, which is what not only what Trump is
doing, but what Maria does.
This is now right wing virtue, signaling they
decry so-called virtue, signaling on the left
to signal that you're part of what I would
call right think.
I mean, the right has two meanings, correct
and right wing.
You have to keep telling lies that most people
now recognize as lies.
And this is not only corrosive to democracy,
it's a global embarrassment.
And we're going to deal with that embarrassment
piece on the Friday show this week.
It is a complete and total global shame that
is taking place here.
And unfortunately, this was not the only such
event over the holiday weekend.
We now have to get to how it went down when
Donald Trump took questions from reporters
on Thanksgiving Day for the first time since
the election